pika vous avez la parole monsieur le
président monsieur le président mes
chers collègues monsieur le premier
ministre
ma question s'adresse à monsieur le
ministre de la santé je ne vais pas vous
parler monsieur le ministre d'un virus
inconnu encore de tous il ya quelques
mois
venu du bout du monde et pour lequel
nous n'aurions pas été prêt je vous
parle d'un virus dans la puissance
contagieuse est connue de tous
mondialement depuis 1918 et pour lequel
un vaccin existe depuis 1944
chacun sait la virulence contagieuse la
virulence saisonnière du virus de la
grippe en nous ne sommes pas prêts nous
ne sommes pas prêts trois chiffres 7
millions de français ont d'ores et déjà
retiré en pharmacie
un vaccin inquiet par la situation
sanitaire qui nous entoure 15 millions
de personnes bénéficieront d'une prise
en charge en fonction de leur situation
à risque or 13 millions de doses
vaccinales ont été seulement préparer
que comptez vous faire monsieur le
ministre pour protéger les habitants de
ce pays pour éviter la rupture de stock
en officine dès cette semaine alors que
nous entrons dans la période optimale
pour se faire vacciner
on vous répondre la parole et dont
secrétaire d'état avait attaqué de la
parole merci monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur belin permettez moi
tout d'abord de vous féliciter pour
votre élection récente et je suis ravi
d'avoir l'honneur de répondre à votre
première question en tant que sénateur
car j'ai apprécié j'ai apprécié le
travail que nous avons pu mener ensemble
l'année dernière en tant que président
du conseil départemental de la vienne
sur la protection de la protection de
l'enfance
alors cette campagne de vaccination vous
l'avez évoqué a débuté le 13 octobre
dernier elle se poursuivra jusqu'au 31
janvier prochain et votre question et la
presse a fait écho d'un certain nombre
de questions qui sont légitimes d'une
part
tout le monde doit-il se faire vacciner
et aurons-nous suffisamment de vaccins
alors concernant la première la première
des interrogations rappeler à la haute
assemblée que la haute autorité de santé
a rendu dès le 20 mai dernier un avis
qui confirmait que cette vaccination
soit doit s'adresser en priorité aux
professionnels de santé aux personnes
les plus fragiles notamment les
personnes âgées et celles qui sont à
risque d'infection grave à la copie de
19 vaccination et professionnelle répond
à un double objectif que je me permets
de rappeler ici pour rappeler aussi aux
professionnels la nécessité de se
vacciner pour protéger tout d'abord les
protéger et leur permette de continuer à
assurer leurs activités de soins est
donc soulagé
l'ensemble du système de soins mais
également protéger les patients avec
lesquels ils sont en contact et
notamment dans les alpes et dans les
hôpitaux dans les établissements
médico-sociaux et dans les ehpad
concernant le nombre de doses
disponibles ensuite qui se réfère à la
question plus précisément que vous posez
ils me permettent de rappeler que
l'objectif de cette campagne vaccinale
n'est pas que 100 % les français soient
vaccinés mais 75% conformément aux
recommandations de l'organisation
mondiale de la santé et compte tenu de
l'anticipation d'une demande accrue
cette année nous avons fait le
nécessaire pour mettre à disposition 30
% de doses supplémentaires par rapport
aux 12 millions consommées lors de la
précédente campagne
ça se traduira par un approvisionnement
continu nous avons bien conscience
phénomène de tension qui peut exister
dans certaines officines mais ces zones
seront constituées par les vaccins qui
sont commandés par les officines par les
laboratoires pharmaceutiques ou encore
les établissements de santé mais aussi
pour la première fois par la
constitution d'un stock d'état je peux
donc vous assurez monsieur le sénateur
que l'état fait tout pour protéger nos
concitoyens contre cette épidémie de
grippe
monsieur renard je craque nous ne
devions le pays de la pénurie pénurie de
médecins pénurie de moyens dans les
hôpitaux pénurie de masques pénurie djel
pénurie sur blues pénurie de tests
pénurie de lits de réanimation pénurie
d'anticipation ce qui est encore plus
grave pénurie de vaccins la préparation
est une faute
monsieur le ministre j'espère que nous
allons nous mobiliser les uns les autres
pour qu' il y ait moins de pénurie et
d'incurie dans ce pays
i
[Applaudissements]